- [Man] Hey.
- Hey.
- [Man] Are you OK?
- Yeah I'm fine.
I just found out that Beyoncé died.
- Get the fuck out!
- No, no, no, my cat,
my cat Beyoncé is dead.
- [Man] Oh.
- I told you about her.
- Right because you
named your cat Beyoncé.
- [Quinta] Yeah.
- Fuckin' ey.
- [Qunita] Well Ashley named it Beyoncé.
I mean it's OK, she was
really old, you know,
I moved out like a year ago,
and Beyoncé's pretty much Ashley's cat.
She wanted to keep her, so I let her.
I just really hope Ashley's doing OK.
(loud sobbing)
- Why couldn't you take me instead?
I can't come in today.
There's been a passing in my family.
(sobbing)
- Rest in peace Beyoncé.
I'll remember you forever.
- [Ashley] Oh thank God!
I thought I'd lost you too.
(sobbing)
- We should get started.
I have to give the caterers a head count
and I still haven't proof read my eulogy.
- What caterers?
- [Ashley] This place is nice.
I can see why you abandoned Beyoncé and I.
- I did not abandon you and Beyoncé.
I had to be closer to work, you know that.
- I know that's what you said.
Can I put this in the fridge?
- Yeah go ahead.
And Ashley don't leave the door open.
This is not a barn!
So what's in that bag anyway?
- It's Beyoncé.
- What?
Excuse me Ashley?
The cat?
- The crematorium wouldn't
take her till tomorrow,
and I didn't want to leave her alone.
- Oh my God Ashley!
Eww!
Ashley why would you put a
dead cat in my refrigerator?
- I thought you'd want to say goodbye.
- I don't want to say goodbye.
What if I eat the cat by accident Ashley?
Did you think about that?
What if I think it's a ham?
Ohh!
And what are you doing with my beers?
- I mean they're going to go
bad if we don't drink them.
(heavy electronica music)
- You don't think any
of this is a bit much?
- Much?
She was your baby.
You're the on who found her
behind an elementary school.
You're the one who nursed
her back to health.
You're the one she slept with.
- Until I went home for Thanksgiving
and she never forgave me.
Every time I gave her her insulin shot
she drew blood for Christ sake.
- She loved hard.
- No, no, no she attacked
our feet at night
any time we tried to go to the bathroom.
- Well who pees after dark?
- Everyone Ashley.
Everyone goes to the bathroom after dark.
And I don't know who you
think you're doing this for,
but it's not for Beyoncé.
(draws breath)
- Yeah.
She was a feral monster OK.
She was a badass,
and she wouldn't want
Bedazzled urns or a special
guest appearance from Justin Guarini.
- Fine!
Then how would you suggest we send her
to her final resting place?
- You know what?
I suggest we send her out like a G.
No chills, no frills, and no caterers.
We take her back to the elementary school
where we found her and we
bury her under the same tree.
Full circle, tonight.
- Quinta, they're never
going to let us do that.
- Ashley my dear, who said
anything about asking?
(heavy guitar music)
- [Quinta] Wait.
Ow, wait, wait.
We can't drive...
- Our faces can't drive.
(laughing)
(heavy music)
- Hi, I need a car.
(French-style music)
- [Ashley] Could you put on Taylor Swift?
- [Quinta] All right, are you ready?
- Yeah let's do this.
- Let's go.
- Wait, where's Beyoncé?
- Beyoncé!
- [Ashley] Shit!
Hello!
- [Quinta] Hey!
- [Ashley] OK let's do this.
- [Quinta] Did you just chuck the cat?
- Sorry Beyoncé.
OK give me a boost.
- [Quinta] Where's the tree?
- [Together] Over there.
(puffing noises)
- [Quinta] Security drive by.
OK they're gone, let's go.
(digging noises)
- This isn't possible.
- No I think we're getting somewhere.
- Oh!
Oh my God!
Is that a femur?
- Oh hell no!
- Who is burying human bodies out here?
- We have to take a break.
- That is nasty!
- That's disgusting.
- Ashley, I'm sorry.
This is crazy.
- No you were right, this is
what Beyoncé would've wanted.
- You think?
- Yeah, you always had
a special bond with her.
- Yeah until we didn't.
- I gave her pie OK.
- You gave Beyoncé human food?
- [Ashley] I'm sorry, it was Thanksgiving,
you had just left, I ate
a whole pie by myself,
I was not in a good place,
and then she just came
crawling onto my lap,
which she had never done before,
and then she started eating the
pumpkin pie with her little tongue.
- Ashley how could you give her pie?
She was a diabetic.
- I know, I know!
But she was so warm, and I was so cold.
And honestly we had
just shared a beautiful
moment watching Pitch Perfect together.
- So, you're saying Beyoncé did love me.
- Of course.
Quinta, I'm sorry I stole your cat.
- I'm sorry I left.
I can't believe she's actually gone.
- I know.
♫I can see her halo, halo, halo
♫I can see her halo...♫
- No Ashley put the cat down.
- I know she smells real
bad, we should bury her.
(heavy guitar music)